We also have a question on SOAP and when to use it? Why you do use it sometimes?
Just clarifying everything about it.
I thought I was clear about on this lecture but maybe I completely misspoke.
We don't use SOAP ever at Reddit or Hipmunk and--
Well, I'll just say some of the providers use SOAP for Hipmunk
because we integrate with lots of lots of people.
It's a nightmare. SOAP is awful. It's a Microsoft technology, so don't use it if you can avoid it.
I think the question was like "Why would you use SOAP over XML or JSON?"
I don't know. You wouldn't. Use XML or JSON. It's a lot easier.
Everybody can parse it. You don't have to do all these complicated Microsoft stuff.
Don't use SOAP.